hookers liars and stinkers that's the
focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
I've never spoken to my son about his
overseas I've never discussed my
business or their business my sons or
daughters and I've never discussed them
because they know where I have to do my
job and that's it and they have to make
their own judgments he's a grown man
and it turns out he did not do a single
thing wrong
I've never seen videos
[Music]
now of course no one not a single adult
alive with any normal brain activity
believes this
the line that Joe Biden wasn't aware of
his son's business dealings is undercut
by Biden's own life story
now from his own words and his own
actions we see that his family means
everything to him their closeness has
been chronicled in profile after profile
going back to his ill-fated 1988
presidential campaign all the way to
present day
it was a family affair
the boys were older
and remarried
had a new daughter
you know he said let's do let's just
test the waters Bowie I love you
I'm so proud of you and I'm also so
proud of my son Hunter and my daughter
Ashley
[Applause]
our whole family
and this sounds corny but we found
purpose in public life
my campaign has always been a family
affair every campaign I've run
in his own words now the president was
so close to Hunter that he brought him
on overseas trips as vice president
including a 2013 trip to China now see
Hunter here in that red sweater enjoy
traditional tea in Beijing
and he continues to travel with his dad
now as president most recently to
Ireland this past April I'm here with my
sister Valerie and my younger son Hunter
Biden Stand Up Guys I'm proud of you
Shameless and of course we know at about
the same time frame that Hunter Biden
was entertaining hookers doing coke and
participating in orgies his longtime
business partner Eric schweren visited
the White House at least eight times
that was in 2016. meeting with then Vice
President Biden's Chief of Staff Steve
ricketti nah nothing to look at here
well the press tried to ignore it all
even when we have hunter in his own
words from one of his Infamous sex tapes
we hear him talking to a Russian
prostitute about how one of his laptops
got stolen
they have videos of me doing this
that basically doing like a couple
degrees
on my computer like taking tons of money
um like just left it like that came on
sounds like an obvious blackmail
possibility and The Prostitute then
asked Hunter if he was worried about
that possibility
yeah getting somebody here
he also knows that I'll make a bazillion
dollars or is it gazillion he also knows
does he mean his dad
it sure sounds like it again Hunter knew
his last name was the only reason why
anyone would want to watch his sex tape
look the facts are overwhelming and not
in dispute first the Biden family has
gotten very very wealthy when they have
no recognizable business Acumen or
anything to offer other than their last
name
second the large sums of money that
Biden's son and brother collected during
his time in office came from
sophisticated people
third those sophisticated players
prepared to pay millions of dollars to
members of the Biden family because they
believed they'd get certain benefits in
return from the U.S government
fourth whistleblowers was reportedly no
partisan motivation have alleged serious
interference by the doj to stymie and
thwart the IRS investigation into Hunter
fifth Hunter's plea deal a couple of
misdemeanors for failing to report a
million bucks in income and no gun
charge no jail time
at the very least it looked suspicious
now here on the angle we try to live in
the real world
every single person in the White House
Press Room knows how all this works
the only defense that they have is that
we can't prove that Biden himself did
lobbying or was directing Hunter's
business
well
either one of two things is going on
here number one that all of Hunter
Biden's clients could have been deceived
by Hunter who Bamboozled them into just
giving him Millions for nothing return
they got nothing or and this is far more
likely that these foreign entities were
getting real value for their money
and a crucial point that I think has
gotten lost here
these foreign interests are now
encouraged to believe that America is
for sale
it doesn't matter if Joe Biden himself
sought out the scheme or knowingly took
a bribe whatever the law says he managed
to get rich off government service
certainly his family did
the answer isn't here I think in
response to this well let's have another
impeachment or let's you know have
another investigation because the only
way to fix this
is if the voters themselves decide to
punish the Democrats and punish them
badly
and again this is why the GOP is going
to be wasting its time if it pursues
endless investigations here right before
a presidential election as tempting as
these possibilities are we all know what
happened here
it's all going to likely backfire by
turning Biden into a martyr
instead we should turn him into a loser
a loser at the polls
and one pillar of the 2024 campaign for
Republicans should be
the bidens are getting richer while your
family is getting poorer or maybe
something like reelecting Biden will
just mean his family will buy another
house as millions of Americans are
forced to sell theirs
it's up to Republican candidates to show
women to show Independence and maybe
even Urban voters why this Biden family
Griff matters we know the Press isn't
going to do it right
well it matters because Biden is
compromised on some of the biggest
issues facing facing the country
including China
you could hear then Vice President Biden
downplaying China and the threat China
posed way back into the 2016 campaign
watch this I've been to China a lot
Chinese are good people
they really are they're decent people we
want China to grow
she asked me why do you want why do you
keep saying you want us to grow I said
so we can sell you our products new
spirit expression and it will still town
these guys aren't a patch on our jeans I
have not met a single world leader who
would even for uh heartbeat
not change places with the problems the
president had versus the problems they
had
funny how the world leaders right now Mr
President are lining up to League juice
boots two and a half years into your
presidency
every good father in America every
single one takes a deep and profound
interest in his child's in this case his
son's business dealings
the whole notion that Joe Biden
personally benefited only if a check was
made out in his name is just ludicrous
if you pay my kids money I have three
kids you pay them money then look you're
making me happy as long as it's you know
on the up and up but you pay kids money
parents feel good about it generally
right
I don't need the money Biden doesn't
need the money and you'd rather have it
go to your kids anyway especially if you
get older
and at his Advanced age Biden probably
does feel that way
like in a way this is his children's
rightful inheritance to get this money
from all these foreign interests
and no doubt all of Hunter clients
realize that and that's the angle hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else